[Music]
all right I think you guys are going to
love this next story especially like
this man named Frederick you guys are
gonna love him so don't tell me no I I
know you I know you will me he's like I
hate him now just true you don't know me
which is really what I mean okay okay so
no matter what I'm right damn it yeah so
Frederick he worked as a manager in a
Parisian perfumery I love him and until
2015 when he sued his former employee
employer because his job was so boring
it made him depressed and force him to
quit and he actually won he won a
$45,000 compensation oh my gosh for
having the most boring job that he had
to quit how could he prove it
the company signed him off work for
several months and then later used his
prolonged absence as an excuse to fire
him in 2014 and then um and so after
four years of litigation is finally when
he won the case but he said that he
ended up going into depression and that
he suffered bore out which is the
opposite of burnout and you think that
was just making up terms I have suffered
poor out because of this yeah so he said
that he had a complete lack of
stimulation at work and in made the man
feel destroyed and ashamed and it even
triggered an epileptic fit when he was
driving at one point because of the bore
I was too strong yeah because he said
that he was deeply ashamed of being paid
to do nothing and then so anyway like
his task it wouldn't involve like
setting up the CEOs new tablet or going
into his boss's home to let a plumber in
perfume
he's just his boss's assistant hey walk
my dog what I work at the perfume store
take the trash well doing hard labor out
there like killing themselves and like I
hate those guys like my job was too
boring give me 45 I would have soup
boring if I knew this is a thing I
worked at boring it was the most boring
job ever I'm supposed to be a plain
scheduler which essentially okay so see
you order a car online and you say I
want a pickup truck
with tinted windows in four-wheel drive
or whatever like that's how planes are
basically ordered online that just cost
30 million dollars or not yeah they're
expensive so I would essentially put in
you know Southwest Airlines once a 737
with this wingding but it's like
glorified data entry they give you the
email that has all the information you
just basically put it into a glorified
excel sheet so I'd have to do four of
those four days a week every other week
and doing one full plane took 30 minutes
so on a busy of the busiest day I had to
work for two hours the other week I had
literally zero responsibilities after
that go to the office still had to go to
the office you do that all day I watched
just kiding films this is when I watched
you two for like eight hours a day I
would and I had to be at work at like
5:00 a.m. so from 5:00 to 8:00 nobody
else would even be there so I wouldn't
have to pretend for the first three
hours I'd take lunch at 10:00 so I was
eating cheeseburgers and dr. pepper red
light because Boeing had like three
shifts and they like the factory was
always working 24 hours a day so a plane
would come in a plane were coming on
just a fuselage basically like this
water bottle empty green and on the 11th
day it would fly like out of the factory
that's how that's how a fishing Boeing
guy and making 737 it was crazy like it
was it was amazing but part of that
efficiency is you have to build a lot of
engineering hours and that was my job so
to make that plane 30 million dollars
you have to say people are doing all
this stuff but it's basically they had
fine-tuned it to perfection you ever
seen a Silicon Valley yeah yeah big big
head
how they like kept him on but but they
love but he didn't have a job really and
so he had to just go to the roof every
day and yes that was new people you were
a roof person did I did data entry [ __ ]
I feel I used to sell printer toner but
part of my job was to distribute it at
lockdown right
so Lockheed Martin and North are
governed huge defense contractors they
all had printers and even NASA was part
of it too and they all needed like black
cyan magenta or yellow that's there
that's what goes into a printer right
and so I would have to dispatch a team
to all these sites when the toner was
low and I would tell them this needs
magenta those needs black person inside
that's how [ __ ] boring that [ __ ] was
and they don't know how to fill the
polluter back now but in the yellow I
can't I don't know how to manage it
maybe [ __ ] pants to NASA people are
[ __ ] [ __ ] do their thing yeah I
know but I'm like what with a digital
era stop killing trees over there you
pieces of [ __ ] use tablets and stuff but
singing I mean the aisle like their old
ways and they all need to print out some
[ __ ] then you wouldn't have your job
well look all I know is that I'm a
printer toner guy so I can tell NASA how
to do their jobs that's true that's how
you do it yeah my first job was just
filing at a bank and it was like
literally taking papers and putting them
in like an alphabetical order like if
someone's name was or whatever like I'd
have to like put it in alphabetical
order for like three hours
oh good I don't know you guys are saying
all this has like a horrible experience
but like I really love organizing [ __ ]
yeah like just like menial tasks like
that like very like the procedural just
want to do four or tedious that's the
word you're looking for it tedious task
like oh your love much work for you yeah
I will pay you
I would love just looking data entry is
the definition of the employee mindset
the beginning I don't even like filling
out my information I'm gonna buy
something online means like I can do it
myself
yeah that's what I love Apple pay man I
just don't even want to put any I don't
if my address is incorrect I just don't
want to buy it anymore just like I just
can't I cannot put my zip code in what
my [ __ ] credit card number Oh
everything Ryan goes what's the security
code I'm like oh go downstairs for that
you put it on your nose and then you
lock the note no I know but but my
credit cards are all in my phone and if
I leave my phone downstairs how lazy
we've become our logs in the drawer were
advancing so we're not lazy we're just
working better and you probably didn't
need that thing anyway then not a thing
I need it in a long time I buy stuff so
I can have something to look forward to
people make fun of me for that but even
like batteries I'm like oh [ __ ] the
remote needs batteries but then I feel
guilty if I only have like two things in
the car I'm like I gotta wait till at
least it's like five ten I do that why
don't I do that it was on prime it's
like this shipping doesn't matter like
what the cost or how many items so I
just be like ordering and then like two
hours later but oh yeah then you bobby
pins no feels like for me I end up
feeling guilty that they bring me a big
old box just for one thing where I'm
like you could've fit way more things in
this oh yeah
yeah if you do it all in the same day
sometimes they can take those orders and
compress them
anyway we're talking about this guy here
that's sued the company for a bore out
this is what he looks like
it doesn't sound like he's he won
because of the boredom it sounds like he
won because he was fired without a good
reason
I mean that's what I heard the way that
they they write this out though it is
they do say that the judge agreed that
because of the amount of poor out or
whatever that it was a form of moral
harassment Wow yeah so he didn't have an
option to quit like what is Your Honor I
would like to demonstrate my average day
at work
Vick then quit [ __ ] no judges
like was it the whole movie office space
about that yes I love that movie I love
my judges fantastic such a good movie
yeah yeah so they did mention here that
the Paris Court of Appeal ruled that
bore out was a form of moral harassment
and that it didn't order inter Parfum
which is the company to pay its former
manager four hundred thousand as he had
originally requested but instead they
opted for little over 10 percent of that
as compensation so so basically what he
would have made if he didn't get fired
seems like it and and they're also
saying that it wasn't even that four out
wasn't even a term recognized by a
French love Malaysia when he sued the
employer back in 2014 but now apparently
it's like now it's gonna set a precedent
yeah actually I was gonna be in America
America leads the league in terrible
lawsuits so I was really surprised it
was it was France
yeah um yeah it was is he about come
again this week is it book out well I
mean does the company did bring up to
like like what the hell like he never
complained about his boring ass job who
would that's chill simulation during his
four years at this
company you give the money back not
until he found out he was getting fired
then he decided to complain plus the
French workweek is so sick dude yeah
there was like two and a half days I'm
not tired
they take like five hour lunch breaks
Italy's like that to Italy shuts down
for like three hours
yes there yeah you can't even get no
food it's crazy I was over there like
I'm American
oh yeah we want food all the time I'm
wearing Amsterdam like and we want all
we want all the time please I need this
now if I want to talk money and I want
it now
Guinea you can't no cuz I could never
not leave the city for that reason
because I can't go back we go to Santa
Barbara sometimes it's like 8 o'clock at
night and you can't order anything what
the [ __ ] my wife loves Santa Barbara for
that reason yeah it's our favorite place
to go like like a little getaway yeah
super quiet everything close it like Oh
7:45 bedtime will you don't forget yeah
that's true like I've been trying to
make plans whenever we go back I'm like
okay we'll go out tonight like with my
old friends and it becomes eight and
it's like yeah I sleep the whole vibe
did you guys have to have a house
parties there yeah there's no nightclubs
in Santa Barbara there is there's State
Street it's just like where things go to
a nine just a college town it's a
college town in a retiree town mmm is
that UC Santa Barbara yeah well there's
there's five colleges yeah there's City
colors there's UC Santa Barbara
there's Westminster there's Brooks
photography and there's one other one I
can't remember but it's either you're
young or you're old
yeah there's no one between we're tired
and there's not a lot of like
headquarters there so like it's hard to
get like a good job job so do multiple
work either in like the service industry
or at the universities yeah basically or
they retire right thanks tree my dad's a
CPA so like that's always needed
and then my mom was a vice president of
a bank but she probably got bore out by
it so she could have won
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]